[موسيقى]
وصلتنا يا صهيب شراير وهذه العربيه 360
الخبر من كل زواياه ومن جميع جوانبه
بعد اتفاقيه الغواصات يكشف عن تطمينات
بابقاء استراليا غير نوويه والجارديان
تتحدث عن ثغره خطيره
[تصفيق]
تبادلنا للتهامات حول حادث اسقاط مسيره
امريكيه فوق البحر الاسود بين موسكو
واشنطن والاخيره تستدعي سفيره روسيا
الاسد يصل موسكو في اول زياره رسميه بعد
الزلزال للقاء بوتين ففصل اللقاء غائبه من
الطرفين
ولدينا ايضا في العربيه 360
بعد تحول منزله لساحه حرب عمران خان يدعو
مناصريه لمواصله الكفاح وان اعتقل او قتل
على يد الشرطه
[موسيقى]
نبدا العربيه 360 هذه الليله من شراكه
اوكوس التي ستطلب تحسين كبيرا للقواعد
الصناعيه للدول الثلاث امريكا بريطانيا
واستراليا اما الاثر فلا يظهر في المستقبل
القريب هذا هو وصف مسؤول امريكي كبير
للاتفاقيه التي اكتملت بالامس والتي قد
تغير خارطه التوازنات في منطقه المحيط
الهادئ والهندي عبر الغواصات النوويه لكن
الطرفين المعارضين الصين وروسيا لن ينتظرا
ظهور الاثر اذ شناه هجوما عنيفا على
الاتفاقيه واعتبرتاه انها تثير المزيد من
التوتر في المنطقه
المواجهه لن تكون ثنائيه بين واشنطن وبكين
في منطقه المحيطين الهندي والهادئ وانما
متعدده الاقطاب هذا هو الحال الذي فرضته
اتفاقيه شراء استراليا لغواصات هجوميه
تعمل بالطاقه النوويه بموافقه امريكيه
بريطانيه تحت ما يعرف باتفاقيه اوكوس ما
يضع الصين امام اكثر من خصم وقوه فالصفقه
التي ستبلغ تكلفتها نحو 245 مليار دولار
وستنفذ على مدار العقود الثلاثه المقبله
هدفها القريب هو بناء قوه بحريه ثابته
لمواجهه توسع النفوذ بكين في المنطقه اما
الهدف الابعد فهو جعل واشنطن قادره على
الاستفاده من حلفائها في مواجهه الصين دون
ان تكون وحيده امام قوه بكين البحريه
وزير دفاع استراليا
اكد ان الصفقه الغواصات النوويه كانت
ضروريه لامن بلاده في وقت تشهد منطقه
المحيط الهادئ اكبر حشد عسكري تقليدي في
المنطقه منذ الحرب العالميه الثانيه
نشاهد النظام العالمي القائمه على القواعد
يتعرض لضغط هائل في اوروبا الشرقيه وفي
المحيطين الهندي والهادئ ونحن نشهد اكبر
حشد عسكري تقليدي شاهدناه منذ الحرب
العالميه الثانيه وهذا يحدث داخل منطقتنا
وعلينا الرد على ذلك
اما الصين وبلهجه شديده ادانت معتبرته
الطريق الخاطئه والخطر الذي تسلكه الشراكه
المبرمه بين الولايات المتحده وبريطانيا
واستراليا ضمن برنامج الغواصات
الصين تشدد على ان اتفاق بين امريكا
واستراليا وبريطانيا سيقود نظام عدم
انتشار الاسلحه النوويه ونعبر عن اعتراضنا
الشديد عليه لانه يبين ان هذه الدول
الثلاث تغاضت عن القلق الذي عبرنا عنه
واختارت الطريق الخطا
موقف روسيا لا يقل حده عن حليفتها
الاستراتيجيه اذ اتهمت اطراف الاتفاقيه
بتدبير مواجهه تستمر لسنوات في اسيا
العالم يبني تكتلات مثل اوكوس ويطور البنى
التحتيه لحلف شمال الاطلسي في اسيا ويراهن
بجديه على مواجهه تستمر لسنوات طويله
الولايات المتحده تبذل مساعي لاخضاع دول
اسيا لارادتها هذا يجب ان يتوقف
اتفاق ثلاثي تقابله معارضه من روسيا
والصين وسيجبر الاخيره على التفكير اكثر
من مره قبل الاقدام على اي مواجهه تدور
حول تايوان او غيرها لان الخصم لم يعد
واحدا وانما ثلاثه ولكل منهم قوته الضاربه
اسعد باستضافه الدكتور علي اسلام وهو رئيس
هيئه الطاقه الذريه المصريه الاسبق دكتور
اهلا بكم معنا في العربيه 360 تكنولوجيا
الغواصات العامله بالدفع النوويه هي
تكنولوجيا كانت التشاركها للولايات
المتحده مع
بريطانيا فقط الان ستتشارك هذه
التكنولوجيا مع كمبيرا مع استراليا كذلك
ما الذي نعرفه عن هذه التكنولوجيا
التكنولوجيا الغواصات العامله بالدفع
النووي
مساء الخير
انا بقول حاجه معينه ان هو في فارق بين
الغواصات النوويه التي تستخدم غواصات
تستخدم صواريخ نوويه
والغواصات النوويه التي
تستخدم فيها الطاقه النوويه للدفع يعني زي
حاملات الطائرات او الغواصات اللي هي
ممكن ان هي تحمل غواصات صواريخ نوويه ولكن
ممكن تستخدم
صواريخ عاديه ممكن تستخدم مدافع تقليديه
او صواريخ تقليديه
فالقضيه في انه نسبه تخصيب اليورانيوم
تختلف من بلد لاخرى يعني اللي موجود في
المعلومات اللي منشوره انه
فرنسا مثلا عندها حاملات الطائرات شارلي
جول بتستخدم للدفع
الحامله الطائرات يورانيوم موثره او مخصب
لدرجه 20% فقط فهذا يعني اسلم من ناحيه
الانتشار النوم اما الغواصات الاخرى اللي
هي موجوده في
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
وبريطانيا بتستخدم
[موسيقى]
اسراء يصل الى
93% طيب دكتور علي اذا الولايات المتحده
وبريطانيا تتشاركان هذه التكنولوجيا مساله
الغواصات المدفوعه نوويا
الاعلان تحالف اوكوست ازعج كثيرا الصين
وروسيا
وان كان يعني لن يرى اثر يعني هذا التعاون
الا في 2040 هل الصين سؤال تمتلك يعني
تكنولوجيا تضاهي هذه التكنولوجيا
الامريكيه اقصدون الغواصات المدفوعه
النوويا يا ترى
لا هي في يعني هي طبعا من المؤكد ان عندها
هذه
التكنولوجيا ولكن
التطور بتاع طبعا الولايات المتحده
وانجلترا اسبق في هذا في هذا المجال
الخطر من من
الانين من انتشار هذه التكنولوجيا الى
اطراف اخرى ويمكن اللي يقال انه مش مش
استراليا هي المقصوده ولكن ان يشجع ذلك
اطراف اخرى بان تستغل هذه مثل هذه
مثل هذه التكنولوجيا
كسابقه
للاعطاء التكنولوجيا النوويه المتطوره
لانه الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه الذريه
واتفاقيه الضمانات اتفاقيه منع انتشار
الاسلحه النوويه واتفاقيه الضمانات
ما فيهاش بند بيقول انه ما ينفعش اي دوله
تستخدمني على المقاطعه ولكن اوصلتنا الى
نقطه هامه جدا هي التي سنناقشها معك بعد
استعراض مخاوف الوكاله الدوليه التقديريه
من هذه النقطه بالذات مشاهدينا هناك طرف
اخر معني بهذه الاتفاقيه وهو الوكاله
الدوليه للطاقه الذريه التي اكد مديرها
العام رفع الجروسي في بيان ان دول تحالف
اوكوس قدمت للوكاله الضمانات باحتفاظ
استراليا بوضعها كدوله غير نوويه في حال
تسلمها للغواصات النوويه وان الرسائل
الدول اكدت ان استراليا لا تعتزم تقسي
باليورانيوم او اعاده معالجته او تصنيع
الوقود النووي في اي مرحله
لكن لماذا الجدل حول موضوع التخصيب
الجارديون البريطانيه سلطه الضوء على ثغره
في اتفاقيه اوكوس تثير المخاوف بشان زياده
الانتشار النووي عالميا وخرق معاهده عام
1968 هذه الثغره توجد في الفقره الرابعه
عشره من الاتفاق وتسمح للمواد الانشطاليه
المستخدمه في الاغراض العسكريه غير
المتفجره مثل الدفع البحري ان تعفى من
عمليه التفتيش والمراقبه من وكاله الطاقه
الذريه وهو ما سيحدث في حال او في حاله
الغواصات النوويه الاستراليه واليوم اتهمت
الصين كلا من الولايات المتحده والمملكه
المتحده بانتهاك هدف
معاهده حضره انتشار الاسلحه النوويه او
انتهاك هذه المعاهده باختصار
دكتور علي هنا اعود اليك هل حقا هذه
الاتفاقيه مع استراليا تخرق معاهده حظر
الانتشار النووي
معاهده حظر الانتشار النووي بتقوم على 3
محاور اللي هو المحور الاول اللي هو انه
الدول النوويه بالفعل اللي هم الخمس دول
نوويه العظمى لا تساعد اي دوله او تنقل
لها التكنولوجيا التي تستخدم لانتاج
الساحه النوويه او اي
متفجرات نوويه
الجانب التاني منع انتشار الاسلحه النوويه
ان الدول التي ليس لديها صحه نوويه لا
تسعى لامتلاكها باي صوره من الصور الركيزه
الثالثه بتقول انه الدول التي تمتلك اسلحه
نوويه تسعى لنزع السلاح
بالشامل هذه الفقره طبعا لم تنفذ الى الان
اطلاق وبالتالي نقل اليورانيوم او الوقود
النووي الى استراليا الا يعد خرقا في هذه
الحاله دكتور علي
طبعا استراليا موقعه على معاهد المقاهي
على حاجتين وقائع على معاهده من انتشار
الاسلحه النوويه سنه 68
وموقعه كمان على البروتوكول الاضافي
بروتوكول الاضافي بيقول ان الوكاله
الدوليه للطاقه الذريه لها ان تتحقق من
جميع المنشات النوويه في استراليا
بالتفصيل في اي وقت
وفي اي مكان فهو طبعا مفروض ان هو
الدوله اللي بتستخدم هذه التكنولوجيا لا
يجب ان هي تكون
بتخضع لتفتيش كامل من الوكاله الدوليه
للطاقه الذريه وغير ذلك يكون خطا هو
الخطوره من انه تعتبر هذه سابقه
لدول اخرى لتستخدم هذا الطريق لانه ده
طريق خطر والمفروض انه الدول نفسها ما
تسعاش الى انتشار الاسلحه ولكن دكتور علي
مباعد في القلق لدى الوكاله الدوليه
للطاقه الذريه هل الامتلاك دوله غير نوويه
لمواد نوويه او غواصات تعمل بالطاقه
النوويه ام ربما من تسرب اشعاعي ما يعني
ما هي بواعث القلق الحقيقيه من هذا
الاتفاق دكتور
البواس القلق الحقيقيه ان التكنولوجيا
اللي موجوده بتستخدم
اسراء عالي جدا
اسراء 93% علشان تقدر الغواصه تستمر
بدون اي تغيير للوقود لمده 30 سنه
فهذه الكميه من اليورينيوم من المصره لو
وقعت في تحت ظروف معينه في
دوله اخرى ممكن من سهل جدا استخلاص منها
اليورينيوم اللي يقدر يستخدم مباشره في
انتاج اسلحه
فهو هذه الخطوره اما في قنبله نوويه اما
انه لو كان الاتجاه العالمي حاليا ان هو
حتى الكونجرس الامريكي بيطالب ان هو
غواصات النوويه 93% تستخدم تكنولوجيا تكون
ضد الانتشار اللي هي 20% لا يمكن
استخدامها مباشره لانتاج قنبله نوويه او
هذه الخطوره ويجب انه
انه ان الدول كلها تسعى لمنع انتشار
السلاح النووي اشكرك شكرا جزيلا على تلبيه
دعوه العربيه 360 هذه الليله الدكتور علي
اسلام انتم رئيس هيئه طاقه الذريه المصريه
الاسبق مباشره من القاهره
[موسيقى]
في العربيه
ثلاثين بعد قليل
متى تواصل عمليات التسريح والضحيه عشره
الاف موظف
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد اعلنت واشنطن استدعاء
السفير روسيا بعد ارتطام مقاتله الروسيه
بمسيره امريكيه فوق البحر الاسود بينما
نقلت سفرتها في موسكو رساله احتجاج
للخارجيه الروسيه وكان المتحدث باسم مجلس
الامن القومي الامريكي بالبيت الابيض جون
كيربي قال ان الرئيس جو بايدن على علم
باصطدام المقاتله الروسيه والمسيره
الامريكيه فوق البحر الاسود كان يعتبر ان
اعتراض المقاتله الروسيه للمسيره كان غير
امن وغير احترافي مضيفا انها لم تشكل اي
تهديد وكانت تقوم بمهمه في الاجواء
الدوليه واوضح البيت الابيض ان وزاره
الخارجيه الامريكيه ستبلغ المسؤولين الروس
بمخاوف واشنطن بعد الحادث وشدد كيربي على
ان الولايات المتحده ستواصل خدمه مصالحها
الامنيه في البحر الاسود مشيرا الى ان
واشنطن لا تحتاج الى تنسيق مع روسيا عندما
تقوم بالتحليق فوق البحر الاسود
وكانت القياده المركزيه الامريكيه
الاوروبيه اعلنت انها اضطرت الى اسقاط
طائره مسيره من طراز ريبر فوق البحر
الاسود بعد اعتراضها من قبل مقاتلات
الروسيه وقالت القياده الامريكيه ان
المقاتلات الروسيه نفذت اعتراضا غير امن
للمسيره الامر الذي كاد ان يتسبب في اسقاط
مقاتله الروسيه والمسيره الامريكيه التي
كانت في مهمه اعتياديه مشيره الى انها
اضطرت لاسقاط المسيره تجنبا للحادث
اما المتحدث باسم
فقال ان المقاتلات الروسيه القت الوقود
امام المسيره الامريكيه فوق البحر الاسود
مشيرا الى ان المقاتلات الروسيه اقتربت
بشده من المسيره حتى تسببت في اضرار لها
يناويرك
نواصل تقييم ما حدث ولكن اعتقد حسب تصرفات
الطيارين الروس كان ما فعلوه امرا غير امن
وغير احترافي اعتقد ان تصرفاتهم تتحدث عن
نفسها ما رايناه هو ان المقاتلات القت
الوقود امام الطائره المسيره واقتربت بشده
منها حتى تسببت في اضرار لها نقيم ان ذلك
تسبب في ضرر للطائره الروسيه ايضا حسب
معلوماتنا المقاتله الروسيه هبطت لاحقا
ولن نقول اين هبطت ولكن هذا يظهر كيف كان
الطيارون غير محترفين
هذا ونفت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه روايه
البانتاجون بشان حادث اسقاط المسيره
الامريكيه وقالت ان المسيره اقتربت من
المجال الجويه الروسي فوق شبه جزيره القرم
حسب بيانها واضافت الوزاره ان المسيره
اغلقت اجهزه تعريفها فانطلقت مقاتله
الروسيه كانت في مهمه في المنطقه الى موقع
المسيره ونفت الدفاع الروسيه ان تكون
مقاتلاتها استخدمت الذخيره ضد المسيره
الامريكيه او قامت بالاقتراب بشكل خطير
منها مشيره الى ان المسيره قامت بمناوره
حاده تسببت في خسارتها لارتفاعها وفقدانها
السيطره لينتهي بها الامر بالارتطام بسطح
البحر الاسود
معنى من موسكو السفير اندريه باكلينوفا
الدبلوماسيه السابق اهلا بك معنا السيد
بكالانوف ما مدى خطوره هذا الحادث
او اعتذر طبعا معنى سيد
اعذرني سيد اندريه
اسالك اذا كيف ترى ما مدى خطوره هذا
الحادث واسقاط هذه المسيره فوق البحر
الاسود
لا توجد هناك خطوره يوجد هناك او توجد
هناك زياده في الرهانات من قبل روسيا طبعا
الروايات الروسيه والامريكيه حول هذا
الحدث تختلف مع بعض البعض ولكن واضح تماما
وبعيد عن الكلام الدبلوماسي لوزاره الدفاع
الروسيه وضح تماما ان مسيرات لا تسقط
ببساطه بهذه البساطه فلذلك من جيد يقول
زياد درهانات في بحر الاسود وكذلك تزامن
هذا الحدث مع التصريحات لرئيس والذي نفى
الروايه الامريكيه حول
تفجيرات في انابيب الغاز سالي الشمالي
واحد واثنين اي امريكا اعطت لروسيا فرصه
لتوافق روسيا على الروايه الامريكيه حول
كان هناك المجموعه الاوكرانيه التي شاركت
في ذلك روسيا تركت هذه الفرصه
ورفض
مدبر يعني معنى كلامك تقصد ان
امريكا ارادت الاحتكاك بالمقاتلات الروسيه
فوق البحر الاسود هذا ما تشير اليه
انا اعتقد ان امريكا حاليا قامت بتجاوز
عده الخطوط الحمراء يعني ما الذي تفعل
المسيرات الامريكيه في البحر الاسود هذا
السؤال المطروح خاصه مع الرادارات غير
الشغاله كما تقول وزاره الدفاع الروسيه
هذا السؤال المطروح
والبعض
يفكر او يعتبر ان هذه المسايات قد شاركت
في تنظيم الانفجار في جسر القرمه الروسيه
فلذلك طبعا روسيا تقول ذلك روسيا تقوم
بزياده الرهانات ترسل الرساله لوشنطن دمها
لم تغلق عينيها
الى ابدا الى الى ما تقوم به الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه في
الامر كذلك
لانه واشنطن يعني رفضت هذا الحدث او رددت
باسقاط مسيرتها فوق شبه جزيره القرم التي
تعتبرها روسيا جزءا من اراضيها طبعا ولكن
اذا كان الموضوع مدبرا كما تقول سيد
اندريه او مقصوده فما الهدف منه ما هو
هدفه واشنطن من هذا الاحتكاك مع مع
الطيران الروسي في البحر الاسود
اولا واشنطن تجار تجرب الخطوط الحمراء
بالنسبه لروسيا الحيويه بالنسبه لروسيا
تنظر الى اي مدى روسيا ستصمت هذه المره
نحن نرى ان روسيا لم تكن صامته هي ردت على
من جيده تقول ذلك في بحر الاسود رده بهذا
الحدث بما حصل مع المسيره وردت بكلام
بوتين حول انفجارات او تفجيرات في سله
شمالي واحد واثنين فلذلك على ما يبدو
الهدف الروسي في هذا المجال هو وهذا
الخطوط الحمراء الحقيقيه
لوشنطن ارجو ان تتفضل بالبقاء معنا ساعود
اليك بعد قليل
ومشاهدينا في ملف الحرب في اوكرانيا قال
رئيس فاجنر التي تقاتل قوته على الخطوط
الاماميه قال انه يوجد 70 الف جندي
اوكراني في باخمت ومحيطها وانه انهم
يستعدون لهجوم مضاد لعزل مقاتله ريغوجين
اوضح ان معركه المعركه تزداد قسوه كلما
اقتربت قوته من وسط المدينه مع استخدام
كثيف
للمدفعيه واضافها ان الاوكرانيين
يلقون باحتياطات لا نهايه لها في المعركه
في الاثناء وخلال اجتماعنا مع قائدته
العسكريين قرر الرئيس الاوكراني استمرار
الدفاع عن ضخمه مشيرنا في بيان الى ان هذا
القرار اتخذ بالاجماع وانه لا تنازل عن
المدينه وياتي هذا الموقف رغم تقارير
امريكيه عديده عن نصيحه واشنطن بالتخلي عن
باخمه
من ناحيه اخرى امر وزير الدفاع الروسي
بمضاعفه انتاج الاسلحه التكتيكيه عاليه
الدقه خلال زيارته الى شركه الاسلحه
الصاروخيه التكتيكيه قال شايغو ان الشركه
تفي بمتطلبات الانتاج المحلي لكن تنتظرها
تحديه مضاعفه تحديات مضاعفه الانتاج
واعتبر وزير الدفاع الروسي ان المؤسسه
تمتلك كل الاحتياطات الضروريه من
المتخصصين ذوي المؤهلات العاليه والمنشات
ومرافق لتنفيذ مهمتها
ومشاهدينا الاهتمام الروسي بملف الذخائر
الذكيه ياتي بعد ان ثبتت اهميتها الكبيره
في الحرب الاوكرانيه وتميل الكفه مشاهدينا
لصالح واشنطن في هذه النوعيه فالقنابل
الذكيه مشاهدينا التي قدمتها الولايات
المتحده لاوكرانيا تتفوق على نماذج
الذخائر الروسيه الموجهه بدقه بحسب خبراء
عسكريين نتحدث هنا مشاهدينا عن القنبلتين
الموجهتين الامريكيه جيدام والروسيه كاب
لنرى الاختلافات بينهما بين القنبلتين اذا
القنبله الامريكيه مشاهدينا يصل المداهه
الى نحو 72 كيلومترا مقارنه ب 14 كلم فقط
لقنبله كاب الروسيه العامل المشترك بين
القنبلتين هو ان كليهما يطلق من المقاتلات
الحربيه وهما موجهان بالليزر او بالاقمار
الصناعيه لكن القنبله جيدام الامريكيه
تتفوق في كونها مقاومه للتشويش على نطاق
واسع ويمكنها البقاء في مسارها الصحيح هنا
نتحدث عن نظام تحديد المواقع العالميه جي
بي اس ونسخته الروسيه جلونس التي يمكن
تشويشهما لكن تعتمد قنابل جيدام على نظام
خاص يعمل على حساب قياسات السرعه وموقع
الهدف سلاح الجو الامريكي اعلن عن تقديم
القنابل الذكيه لاوكرانيا في ديسمبر
الماضي وتم استخدامها في المعارك بالفعل
ننتقل الان مشاهدينا اخيرا للقنبله
الروسيه كاب التي يحتوي او تحتوي على راس
حربي شديده الانفجار ويعتقد خبراء عسكريون
انها استخدمت لقصر مسرحين في مدينه
ماريوبل الاوكرانيه في مارس من العام
الماضي اضافه الى استخدامها المتكرر ايضا
في سوريا
[موسيقى]
وفي ملف غير بعيد قالت الامم المتحده ان
المشاورات بشان اتفاق تصدير الحبوب
الاوكرانيه مستمره على جميع المستويات
وذلك بعد ان وافقت روسيا على تمديد
الاتفاق لمده شهرين فقط بدلا من اربعه
اشهر
لكن مشاهدينا هناك اهميه ابعد لاتفاق
تصدير الحبوب والمطالبه الروسيه المتعلقه
بالسميدتها فموسكو تعد اكبر مصدر للاسمده
في العالم بحسب
الاحصاءات اغلب الصادرات هذه تتوجه الى
البرازيل والهند والصين واستونيا وغيرها
من الدول لكن الاسمده الروسيه باتت موطئه
قدم للتحالف السياسي بين روسيا ودول
افريقيه وعلى راسها جمهوريه مالاوي العام
الماضي وافقت روسيا على التبرع ب 260 الف
طن من الاسمده للدول الافريقيه الاكثر
عرضه لخطر انعدام الامن الغذائي مالاوي
كانت احدى هذه الدول المستقبله للاسمده
وخاصه تلك المتبرعه بها واستقبلت الشهر
الماضي عشرين الف طن هذه الدوله استعانت
بشركه الكيماويات الروسيه اوراكليم
اورالاكي اورالاكلي والتي يخضع مؤسسها
لعقوبات غربيه وزير الزراعه الملاوي اشاد
بالتبرع الروسي وقال ان الوالدات الاخيره
من روسيا ستساعد في انتاج 800,000 طن من
الذره واطعام 400 الف اسره الدعم الروسي
ذو الاهميه بالنسبه لملاوي خاصه ان 80% من
مواطنيها يعتمدون بشكل كامل او شبه كامل
على الزراعه
في السياق تحاول الحكومه في ملاوي
وبمساعده المنحين الدوليين دعم اسعار
الاسمده المستورده وكان ارتفاعه الاسعار
دفع الكثير من المزارعين للتوجه نحو زراعه
البقوليات بدلا من الذره التي تعد زراعتها
تحتاج للكثير من الاسمده وحذر برنامج
الغذاء العالمي من ان غياب الاسمده عالميا
سيزيد من المخاوف في حدوث نقص غذاء في
فتره الحصاد وزير الزراعه في ملاوي شدد
على ان بلاده غير مهتمه بمصدر الاسمده او
بكونها اداه جيوسياسيه معتبرا ان روسيا
اتت لانقاذ مالاوي عندما كانت في امس
الحاجه للدعم
اعود الى ضيفي من موسكو المحلل السياسيه
الروسي سيد انتقاد هل تعتقد ان مده 60
يوما هي مده كافيه الحقيقه
لتمديد اتفاقيه تصدير الحبوب من الموانئ
الاوكرانيه كما وافقت روسيا
هذا كافي لاتخاذ القرار على مستويات
المختلفه حول الرفع عدم الرفع الى
العقوبات عن الشركات الروسيه والبنوك
الروسيه المختصه
بالمكافات مقابل الهديه للاسمده والحبوب
وكذلك عن الناقلات الروسيه التي
تنقل الحبوب الى دول الثالثه فلذلك روسيا
يمكن ان نقول
يعني اخذت او اتخذت حلا وحل وسط في هذا
المجال نار الوسط من قبل الروسي
لماذا لماذا ستون يوما لماذا ليس اكثر من
ذلك
هذا السؤال جميل جدا انا يمكن ان اقول ان
البعض يربط هذا القرار الروسي بالانتخابات
في تركيا بسبب
لا لا تريد رؤوسا هديه
لمنافسه اردوغان في هذه الانتخابات لا
تريد ان تضرب المواقف اردوغان في هذه
الانتخابات هذه هذه من جهه من جهه اخرى
انا ذكرت سابقا بان تم التجاهل لمصالح
الروسيه خلال هذا الاتفاق الحبوب فيها
سابق في روسيا ايضا تقول للجميع هنا
لاتخاذ القرار حول الرفع
قلت انه المصالح الروسيه جر تجاهلها في
اتفاق تصدير الحبوب ما هي هذه المصالح
ماذا تقصد
انا اقصد بان بقن للاتفاق الحبوب كان على
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه وحلفائها
الرفعه للقوات عن قطاع الزراعي قطع
الناقلات لتلك الحبوب يعني جزر او بعض
البنوك التي
تتخصص
بتبادلات المعلومات التجاريه تعبادلات
المكافات على تلك الحبوب لم يحصل ذلك
فتوجد هناك كثير من العوائق حول تصدير
لحبوب والاسمده الروسيه الى الخارج
فلذلك روسيا تقول بان يجب ان يكون هناك حل
الحقيقه لانه روسيا شاهدناها تقدم الاسمده
مجانا الى الدول الافريقيه الى دول
الافريقيه منها مالاوي كما ذكرنا في الخبر
السابق فهل هي تريد يعني ان تستفيد من
عائدات هذا التصدير يعني اذا كانت تريد عن
مكاسب لتصدير الاسمده فهي تقدم الاسمده
بالمجان الى دول افريقيه فما الذي تريده
روسيا تحديدا
ان الرئيس بشار الاسد وصل مساء اليوم الى
روسيا في زياره رسميه يجري خلالها محادثات
مع رئيس روسيا وتاتي الزياره بعد قرابه
عام ونصف من اخر زياره لبشار الاسد الى
موسكو منتصف سبتمبر عام 2021 ولم يكشف
الجانبان عن تفاصيل الزياره او الملفات
محل النقاش
[موسيقى]
نقلت صحيفه ووست جورنال عن مصادر مطلعه
قولها ان وزاره العدل الامريكيه وهيئه
البورصات الامريكيه حقيقه في انهيار بنك
سيليكون فالي واوضحت المصادر ان تحقيقات
ما زالت في مراحلها الاولى وقد لا تؤدي
الى اتهامات او مزاعم بارتكاب مخالفات
وكانت حده المخاوف الامريكيه من حدوث ازمه
شامله في القطاع المصرفي قد هدات وتحول
المستثمرون الى اسهم البنوك من جديد بعد
ان تراجعت على مدار ثلاث جلسات متتاليه
الاجراءات التي اتخذها الفيدرالي والتي
كان من اهمها ضمان ودائع بنكي
المتعثرين ساهمت في اعاده بعض الثقه
للقطاع كما ان اطلاق الفيدرالي لبرنامج
التمويل البنكي لاجل بنك
بروجرام والذي سيقدم قروضا للمؤسسات
لمؤسسات الايداع مدعومه بسندات الخزانه
الامريكيه والاوراق الماليه المدعومه
بالرهن العقاري قد ساهم بتهدئه المخاوف
ايضا
جهه اخرى اعلن تم مايو بولوس الرئيس
التنفيذي الجديد للكيان الجديد للمؤسس تحت
شركه تامين على الودائع الفيدراليه
تم نقل جميع ودائع اصول بنك اسفي المتعثر
او سيليكون
اكد اعاده مزاوله الاعمال داخل الولايات
المتحده مشيرا الى ان الاعمال عبر الحدود
ستستانف في الايام المقبله وكان
ماريوبولوس اكد ان المذيعين يمكنهم الوصول
الى اموالهم كما ان الودائع الجديده
والقائمه محميه بالكامل
وخلال مؤتمر صحفيا في برلين طمئن المستشار
الالمانيه
بشان صحه البنوك في البلاد بعد ان اثار
انهيار بنك سيليكون فالي مخاوف من انتشار
الاسماك
يمكنكم ان تروا من خلال رد الفعل الواضح
والحاد للسلطات الامريكيه والبريطانيه
والاوروبيه وكذلك الالمانيه ان هذا الوضع
يخضع لمراقبه دقيقه للغايه وان هذا
الاجراء يتم اتخاذه بسرعه كبيره وهذا افضل
شيء يمكن القيام به من اجل سلامه الودائع
لذلك لا يوجد سبب لاي شخص هنا في المانيا
ليكون قلقا للغايه
معنى من واشنطن
كبير الخبراء الاقتصاديين في مؤسسه
كابلينجر مرحبا بك معنا في العربيه 360
بدايه السؤال الذي يطرحه الجميع هل هناك
ازمه ماليه قادمه بعد هذا الافلاس
لسليكون فالي بنك
ذلك
كانت
حاولت وقف النزيف ولذلك لا اعتقد بان
سيكون هنالك
او التاثير
بنوك اخرى نعم ولكن عمليا كان هناك
بنكان اخران اعلن افلاسهما ديفيد هل
الاجراءات التي اتخذتها الحكومه كما
ذكرتها الفيدرالي الامريكي هي بالفعل
مطمئنه وتؤكد انه لن يحصل الدومينو
لن يكون هناك المزيد من الانهيارات
[موسيقى]
بعض البنوك التي ستواجه الصعوبات من المهم
ان ندركا
ان البنوك الكبرى لم تواجه اي مشاكل
حقيقيه
مختلفه عن بنك سيليكون
الكثيره من اصوله في السندات الحكوميه
القديمه اكثر من نصفها اما اغلب البنوك
اكثر وتنوعا البنوك الكبرى ايضا تمر تحت
التجارب واختبارات الضغوط ولذلك قوي جدا
لكن المشكله مع بنك سيليكون فعلي وسبب
تدخل الحكومه هواء لانه حدد بتاثير
او الاقليميه الصغيره وكذلك بين الشركات
التكنولوجيه وخاصه انها التي ربما ستواجه
المشاكل في تسديد المرتبات نعم طيب هل
يعني هذا هو السبب الوحيد برايك لما حصل
لسليكون فالي بانك
ان الاصول غير متنوعه وبانه مرتبط بقطاع
شركات التكنولوجيا التي تعاني في هذه
المرحله هذه هي الاسباب ام ثمه اسباب اخرى
الرئيسي
اذا كان هناك انعدام سواء
وبين الاصول
من الاصول ولكن
السندات القديمه لم يتمكنوا من
لم تنضج لاحقا
لذلك عندما كان ذلك ايداعات او كثير من
الشركات هرعت لاستعاده اموالها لم تكن
لديهم الاموال لاعادتها وكان بامكانهم
الخروج وبيع السندات هذا الصحيح وقد باعوا
البعض منها بالفعل لان السبب الفائده
ارتفعت كثيرا
قبل
ارتفاع نسبه التضخم وذلك خسروا حوالي 15
مليار دولار في محفظتهم نعم طيب ولكن سيدي
في العموم يمكن القول انه المودعين في
اسبيبه سيليكون فالي بنك قد استعادوا
اموالهم يعني بشكل يعني امن يعني لم تضع
ودائعهم
لم يخسروا اذاعاتهم لان الحكومه
رفعت السقفه وتنازع عن السقف فيما يخص
تامين الوداع الاذاعات الى 250 الف دولار
تكون مؤمنه لهذا البنك
قاره الحكومه
ولكن هنالك بعض التبعات من هذه الحلقه
وهذه الحادثه بنوك اخرى وخاصه البنوك
الصغيره يجب ان تبحث فيها الماليه الشركات
يجب ان تراجع سياسات اداره الاموال هل هل
توزعوا اموالها بشكل اوسع مثلا بلا شك
الفدرالي
يتابع دونك الصغيره في عام 2018 قرر
احتياط الفيدرالي تلاقي البنوك التي ليس
لديها او اقل من 250 مليون دولار من
الاصول ولكن هذا كان خطا وذلك اعتقد بان
فتره سيبدا بالتحقيق في هذه البنوك لدي
سؤال اخير لو سمحت ذكر انه افلاس سيليكون
فالي بانك
له علاقه كذلك بالعملات الرقميه خاصه
البيتكوين هل حقا هناك علاقه وما مستقبل
العملات الرقميه في ضوء ما حصل لاسببه
في الحقيقه ليس بنك
كان مرتبط بالعملات المشفره
حسب فهمي
كانوا ضحايا
التخوف
المذيعون كانوا يتساءلون اذا بما كان
يواجه مشاكل وربما البنوك كثيره للعمل
ستواجه هذه المشكله صحيح ان بنك
مشاكل فيها الائتمانيه مشابهه ولكن
نعم ان فشل السجن بنك
يطيح باحد اللاعبين في مجال العنف المشفره
لذلك بعض التبادل
قد يواجهون المشاكل التي تحقيق العلاقات
البنكيه
لان اصبح هناك مثل الصدع
وهو اختبار بالتاكيد في هذا الوقت
بيان انت كبير الخبراء الاقتصاديين في
مؤسسات شكرا جزيلا لك على انضمامك الينا
مباشره من واشنطن العاصمه
نبقى في قطاع التكنولوجيا حيث تعتزم متى
الشركه الام لفيسبوك تعتزم تقليص عشره
الاف وظيفه اخرى وعدم ملء 5000 وظيفه
شاغره بهدف خفض التكاليف واعلنت متى انها
ستقلل من حجم فريق التوظيف وستجري للمزيد
من التخفيضات في مجموعاتها للتكنولوجيا
اواخر ابريل ثم مجموعاتها للاعمال في
اواخر مايو
[موسيقى]
في العربيه 360 بعد قليل تايوان استوعبت
الدرس الاوكرانيه جيدا اعلنت عن مسيراتها
العسكريه محليه الصنع
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد ادلى مايكل كوهين محامي
دونالد ترامب سابق الذي استحاله الى احد
الذ اعدائه افادى بافادته امام هيئه
محلفين كبرى في نيويورك في اطار تحقيق حول
قضيه دفع اموال لممثله قد يوجه فيها
الاتهام الى الرئيس الامريكي السابق
[موسيقى]
قد تكون هذه المراه شوكه في انتخابات لن
تكتب النصر للرئيس الامريكي السابق دونالد
ترامب في السباق الرئاسي لعام 2024
القضيه الاقرب لاسقاطه هكذا تصنف اذا ما
وجهت التهمه الجنائيه الى ترامب حول دفع
محاميه السابق مايكل كوهن 130 الف دولار
للممثله ستورمي دانييلز ليشتري صمتها قبل
اسبوعين من الانتخابات الرئاسيه التي فاز
فيها المرشح الجمهوري على الديمقراطيه
هيلر كلينتون
ادعاءات خرجت للعلن منذ خمس سنوات ولكنها
اليوم تقترب الى حافه المحاكم مع ادلاء
كوهن الذي استحال الى احد الد اعداء ترامب
بافادته امام هيئه محلفين كبرى في نيويورك
في اطار تحقيق حول القضيه ليؤكد انه ليس
انتقاما وانما يقدم الحقيقه
فبعد سجنه لثلاث سنوات اوضح ماليا انه
تصرف باعاز صريح من الترامب الذي اعاد له
المبلغ فور دخوله المكتبه البيضاوي
النيابه العامه في منهات بدورها استدعت
ايضا ترامب للادلاء بافادته بحسب صحف
امريكيه ما يعني ان توجيها الاتهام الى
الرئيس السابق قد يكون وشيكا
حمله سياسيه شعواء تهدف الى النيل من
المرشح الذي يتقدم باشواط هكذا يصف ترامب
تلك المزاعم حتى حينما ظهرت لاول مره
نفاها مرارا وتكرارا خلال احدى رحلاته
الجويه
وذكرت نيويورك تايمز ان التهمه التي قد
توجه الى ترامب هي القيام بتصريحات حسابيه
خاطئه لاخفاء انتهاك لقواعد تمويل الحملات
الانتخابيه لتصبح عودته الى البيت الابيض
شبه مستحيله في العام القادم
نعرف اكثر من مراسلنا في واشنطن العاصمه
حسين اهلا بك معنا ما تفاصيل هذه القضيه
الجديده بين رئيس السابق دونالد ترامب
والممثله ستورمي دانييلز
تحيه لك صهيب اولا لنبدا بان احد محامي
دونالد ترامب وهو جوتا كوبينا قال بان
لديه اي خطط للوصول امام هيئه المحلفين
الكبرى في نيويورك وهو يكون عاده مثول
طوعي للادلاع بافادته وهذا ما قاله في
احدى لقاءاته مع احداث التلفزيونات هنا في
الولايات المتحده بالنسبه
لمحاميه فان هذه القضيه لا اساس قانوني
لها وبذلك بسبب هذا السبب لا يتوقعون ان
يوجه الادعاء في نيويورك اتهامات واذا
وجهت هذه الاتهامات غير معروفه حتى الان
دونالد ترامب بطبيعه الحال نفى مرارا
وتكرارا بانه قد وجه محاميه السابق مايكل
لدفع مبلغ 130 الف دولار للممثله
هو ينفي ذلك ينفي اقامه علاقه معها ولكن
الممثله قالت بانها تلقت هذا المبلغ من
محاميه بناء على طلب من ترامب
لكن الحسين اعذرني على المقاطعه انا لم
افهم شيئا يعني هو حسب الادعاء انه ترامب
دفعه 130 الف دولار
حتى تصمت ولا تتحدث عن العلاقه التي كانت
تجمعها بالرئيس السابق محاميه السابق
لماذا تحدث عن هذه القضيه اذا
لماذا انقلب على ترامب يجب ان لا ننسى ان
يجب ان لا ننسى ان المحامي اعترف بانه
اعترف بالذنب بانه دفع مبلغ 130 دولار
وتم سجنه بعد ذلك لمده ثلاث سنوات لربما
هذا هو ما دفعه الان لكي ينتقم هو رغم انه
نفى ذلك وقال انه لا يريد الانتقام انما
يريد ان يقول الحقيقه
وصف
كهن بانه جرد وبانه ضعيف في عندما كان في
البيت الابيض عندما كان رئيسا اذا هناك
عداوه بين الشخصين رغم ان كوهن يقود انه
لا يريد ان ينتقل من دونالد ترامب
زميلنا المنتج يقول انتهى الوقت انا كنت
اريد ان اسالك المزيد ولكن سنرى مالات هذه
القضيه وتاثيرها على ترامب لاحقا لانه
اكيد الاعلام الامريكي سيركز عليها بشكل
كبير جدا حسين شكرا جزيلا لك من واشنطن
[موسيقى]
قال وزير الداخليه الباكستاني ارانا ثناء
الله ان الشرطه ستعتقل رئيس الوزراء
السابق عمران خان وستقدمه للمحاكمه
وطلب خان طلب للمثول امام القضاء للرد على
الاتهامات بيع هدايا حكوميه تلقاها خلال
فتره رئاسته للوزراء واخفاء اصول
اشتباكات عنيفه بين انصاره والشرطه في
محيط منزله وصف عمران خان الحكومه
الباكستانيه بحكومه اللصوص داعيا انصره
الى مواصله الكفاح اذا ما تم قتله او سجنه
[موسيقى]
انا احارب معركتكم لقد حاربت طوال حياته
وساواصل ذلك لكن اذا حدث لي شيء ما ودخلت
السجن او قتلت فعليكم اثبات ان هذه الامه
ستستمر في كفاحها بدون عمران خان فهذه
حكومه لصوص ويجب ان لا تقبلوا بذلك ابدا
[تصفيق]
في فيديو اليوم ما تزال اسرائيل تعيش
مشاهدا لم تجربها تقريبا من قبل متظاهرون
يغلقون الطريق امام مكتب نتنياهو بالسلاسل
والانابيب بل وحتى باجسامهم اللازمه الامر
يحاول هؤلاء ان يقطعوا الطريق على من بات
في نظرهم رمزا للدكتاتوريه ففي اسرائيل لم
يعودوا يهمسون بل صاروا يصرخون نتنياهو لا
يصحح من وضع القضاء بل يسعى لتحصين نفسه
من القضاء
وفي تصريح اليوم مسيرتنا محليه الصنع
عمليه وصغيره يمكن حملها في حقيبه على
الظهر وبمقدورها التحليق لمده 15 دقيقه
هذا التصريح هو لمعهد شنكشان الوطني
للعلوم والتكنولوجيا التابع للجيش والذي
اكد ان المسيره تشبه قنبله قنبله يدويه
كبيره قادره على الطيران وان الواضح اذا
ان تايوان استوعبت الدرس الذي مرت به
اوكرانيا ولم تجد افضل مما استعملته
اوكرانيا كي تنسخه فمسيرتها الجديده هي
نسخه من سويتش بليد 300 الامريكيه
صوره اليوم من كييف ينظر الجندي الاوكراني
الى العجوز انطولي وهو يحمل صوره ابنه
يوري الذي قتل في الحرب مع روسيا ويسرح في
صور باقي القتلى خلال الاحتفال بيوم
المتطوعين يستشعر الجندي ما يمر به الاب
فيقرر مواساته يحكي له بطوله من هم مثل
ابنه يحكي له ويؤكد فلتروي هذه القصص لكل
من تعرف لانك عندما تاتي العام القادم
ربما لن اكون موجودا هنا لاحكي ربما اكون
موجودا بين الصور
العربيه 360 انتهت لهذه الليله ولكن فتره
الاخبار المسائيه على العربيه مستمره الان
الى اخبار الساعه في تقديمها الزميل محمد
طميحي محمد مساء الخير اهلا بك في اخبار
الساعه ماذا لديك الليله
شكرا صهيب خلال الاسبوع الماضي في هذا
المكان لتقديم اخبار الساعه والليله
ساصحابكم في اخبار الساعه وبالحديث عن اهم
الاخبار لهذه الليله لا بد من الحديث عن
هذا التصادم وهذه الازمه الجديده في البحر
الاسود بعد اصطدام مسيره امريكيه بطائره
حربيه روسيه سنوك بالتفاصيل لاحقا في
اخبار
الكلمه لك محمد تفضل
[موسيقى]